hi you've reached the voicemail box of
markiplier I can't come to the channel
right now but if you click on the link
in the description below and leave me a
brief message I'll get back to you as
soon as I can
thanks
you
are you still there if you'd like to
rerecord your message press star nine
nine now
then type in star six four two one eight
five three dash ampersand dollar signed
four nine pound and then click on the
link in the description below and leave
me another message thanks sorry
all circuits are busy please try again
later
are you still there if you'd like to
delete your recorded message click on
the link in the description below and
then type in
you
pound one 337 and your message will be
deleted along with everything else
Oh
I'm sorry that was an invalid command
please press whatever the hell you were
trying to type again and I'll get back
to you as soon as I can
in the meantime click the link in the
description below and leave me another
message
Thanks
please hang up and try your call again
if you need assistance dial your
operator please hang up now this are you
still there if you're finished with your
recording you can click on the link in
the description below and
[Music]